un collègue dit à l'oreille de votre
maman madame vous avez un fils
incroyable il fera une grande carrière
dans la banque
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Jean-Paul aloux bonsoir
alors Jean-Paul Alou pour publier chez
Michel Lafont un livre intitulé tous les
banquiers ne finissent pas en prison moi
c'était dans la rue alors ancien
banquier maître de conférence vous
racontez comment vous êtes passé de
l'atmosphère feutrée des grands
restaurants parisiens au monde de la rue
comment vous le nanti parmi les nantis
avaient tout perdu travail famille
maison amis tout
on en reparle à 20h
[Musique]
Jean-Paul rebonsoir vous êtes né le 26
juillet 1952 à Guyon dans l'Yonne votre
mère femme de ménage chez le médecin du
village rencontre votre père à la cave
où il mettait le vin en bouteille le
vrai métier de votre père en fait
c'était cordonnier et à l'arrivée du
caoutchouc il est obligé de travailler
dans une usine métallurgique à Paris
donc vous arrivez à Vincennes à l'âge de
4 ans
vous êtes très débrouillard vous
trouverez rapidement un gagne-pain vous
êtes malin vous allez trier des
bouteilles chez les pisser du quartier
pour faire un peu d'argent vous dites
j'étais un bosseur quoi oui je l'ai levé
dans cette tradition le travail ça fait
partie puis si je voulais de l'argent de
poche il fallait que je le gagne tout
simplement après le bac vous êtes
embauché au Crédit Lyonnais à Vincennes
et là c'est le début d'une irrésistible
ascension professionnelle ça marche très
très bien pour vous dans cette banque
vous marier à la même époque avec
Huguette
qui dessine des patrons de mode chez
Marie-Claire et d'ailleurs le jour du
mariage un collègue dit à l'oreille de
votre maman madame vous avez un fils
incroyable il fera une grande carrière
dans la banque vous êtes fier de votre
mère ah oui les parents mais il y avait
une ambiguïté quand même quelque part
mon père il est ouvrier Métallos quand
même et souvent le soir je l'entends
bouffer du patron quand même quelque
part de voir son fils réussir ça génère
aussi une ambiguïté il est content je
transpire pas comme il a transpiré mais
quelque part je représente aussi un
monde qui qui l'intrigue
alors là en 12 ans vous passez du
guichet à directeur général très très
belle réussite et en 1986 vous quittez
la banque pour ouvrir un cabinet de
consulting et là ça explose
littéralement vous gagnez beaucoup
d'argent vous gagnez jusqu'à 3000 euros
par jour quand même je rougis pas je
veux dire par contre je comprends
parfois un peu l'agressivité de
stagiaires qui a la compta en vue passer
mes factures quoi alors tu l'époque
bénie pour vous évidemment l'argent
coule à flot rien n'est inaccessible
théâtre vernissage gala ou fumer des
monte-cristos vous buvez du vieil
armagnac vous portez des smokings et
quand vous avez envie de faire un petit
week-end ou partez avec Huguette à
Istanbul quoi voilà vous dites c'est
chouette d'être riche sans jouer des
flambeurs mais bon oui c'est chouette
alors pour votre vie professionnelle
vous êtes souvent en formation et un
jour vous arrivez dans un hôtel
où il y a un festival de voyance et là
une bohémienne vous interpelle et vous
dit vous serez veuve très jeune le décès
de votre femme sera très dur pour vous
quatre ans plus tard en juillet 1994
vous êtes en vacances près de Martigues
votre épouse est fatiguée
une nuit elle est réveillée par de
violentes brûlures aux bras et dans le
dos et quand on lui fait des examens on
découvre un cancer généralisé métastasé
sur la moelle épinière les côtes et le
bassin
les médecins disent on lui donne trois
mois non ils me disent il y en a pour
trois mois et il lui disent on va vous
guérir et là ils nous font rentrer dans
le mensonge et je vais beaucoup souffrir
de ce mensonge là alors votre femme
Huguette vous parle d'un traitement
miracle qui est interdit en France à vos
1500 euros
l'injection et évidemment c'est cure
vont engloutir toutes vos économies à
partir du moment où il y a de la monnaie
c'est que l'argent ça va ça vient donc
je me pose pas trop de questions par
rapport à la monnaie c'est ce qu'elle
veut donc bon voilà c'est j'accepte je
paye en 1997 Huguette décède
là vous rencontrez Mathilde donc est une
étudiante beaucoup plus jeune que vous
voilà et puis vous l'avez connu pendant
la guenie de Dugat quoi
oui c'est sûrement le
ce qui va au départ
me traumatisé aussi mais voilà bon c'est
j'enchaîne la vie et
6 mois après vous l'épousez on la faites
pas les choses à moitié sans inviter un
chef trois fois étoilé voyage de noces à
Saint-Domingue voilà quoi là vous
carrément vous commencez à craquer du
pognon pour cette Mathilde mais vous
dites c'est pas grave en fait je gagne
de l'argent vous dit à l'époque je suis
une machine à cash quoi quelque part
j'ai envie de repartir et de de non pas
oublier ce que j'ai vécu dans ces
moments dramatiques mais voilà de me
dire il faut que je partage un certain
nombre de joie ça passe à l'époque j'en
étais convaincu ça passe par
effectivement un échec
alors voilà la vie avec Mathilde vous
coûte cher
je partage non mais elle veut déménager
[Musique]
et là on vous propose de gérer la
fermeture des établissements Matrat à
Romorantin alors vous dites bon j'ai
besoin d'argent j'y vais c'est super
bien payé mais bon là bas Romorantin
vous bossez 18h par jour et vous revenez
en fait à ballon chez vous uniquement le
vendredi soir
vous éloignez de votre famille
inévitablement Mathilde vit assez mal
elle s'enfonce dans la mélancolie et en
avril 2005 elle vous quitte oui j'ai pas
vu venir
j'ai une expérience une histoire passée
avec Huguette elle est brestoises et les
filles de marins que l'homme soit
constamment sur la mer et reviennent de
temps en temps ça a pas été gênant donc
je continue à ce rythme là je suis pas
vigilant je vois pas trop ce qui se
passe du fait que je ramène la monnaie
que mon métier en plus me passionne ça a
été Matra une aventure humaine
extraordinaire bon voilà je je
m'aperçois finalement avec le recul je
partage de la monnaie quoi mais je ne
partage pas grand chose d'autre
alors là non seulement elle vous quitte
mais ensuite il y a combat pour la garde
des enfants là j'ai psychologiquement je
m'effondre ça vous brise cette histoire
et en septembre 2006 vous avez pas de
boulot et vos droits aux assedics sont
épuisés et là c'est terrible ce qui vous
arrive à l'âge de 60 ans vous êtes
obligé de retourner chez papa maman ça
c'est oui épouvantable en plus vous êtes
obligé de raconter c'est une mauvaise
passe vous pouvez pas dire la vérité
de se dire c'est blindespoir parce que
ils ont fait leur vie et se récupérer
leurs gamins à cet âge-là il pensait pas
que c'était possible quoi c'est voilà
donc c'est terriblement humiliant pour
vous
en même temps
désagréable parce que vos parents ils se
lèvent à 6h30 du matin il dit à 19h
c'est pas du tout la vie à laquelle vous
étiez habitué et puis la honte de votre
mère dans le village parce que vous
étiez finalement le môme qui avait
réussi et là on voit traîné il y a eu la
fierté et puis après il faut reste les
murs
là votre père est victime d'Alzheimer
il finit par mourir et votre mère par
s'installer chez sa fille et elle met la
maison en location voilà il y a plus de
maison plus d'aide là il y a plus rien
c'est à dire que d'une part il y a plus
de toi je pense pouvoir être hébergé
chez quelqu'un que j'avais hébergé
pendant plusieurs mois et puis qui me
fait comprendre que bon là autre chose à
faire bon ok et là je me retrouve
effectivement sans toi et puis et puis
sans ressources pour la de ma faute je
trouve des petits boulots que je ne
déclare pas donc je suis dénoncé et là
les allocations me sont supprimées donc
le RMI m'est supprimé et là il y a plus
rien alors vous voulez pas en parler à
vos enfants ni à votre sœur parce que
vous êtes fiers ils ont leurs problèmes
en même temps donc vous dites je vais
pas leur en parler vous retrouver comme
un comme un SDF vous vous retrouvez à
ramasser des mégots pour pour fumer
oui je vais choisir les les beaux
filtres je pense que c'est plus
hygiénique alors que remplir seul
endroit où vous pouvez dormir à l'époque
c'est la Seat Ibiza ou vos et là c'est
toujours un peu la trouille des Tuniques
Bleues parce que j'ai plus mon permis
j'ai plus de points
c'est à dire que j'ai remarqué aussi que
finalement quand on est et ça c'est pas
bien mais quand on est dans une
situation
un peu inextricable et qu'on est dans
l'instinct de survie les solutions qu'on
croit trouver sont les pires vous dites
à ce moment-là je pue je sens le pauvre
c'est ce que je peux sentir et puis je
me souviens coupe d'amis qui me reçoit
et qui me disent bah écoute on t'invite
à manger mais va prendre une douche pour
une cuisine non j'ai envie de manger je
prendrai la douche après et puis elle
insiste elle me dit non je t'assure
vas-y c'est vrai et je me dis ouais
sûrement que l'odeur était parce que oui
la pauvreté a une odeur c'est clair quoi
parce qu'on peut pas se laver tous les
jours c'est la course à l'eau alors là
vous vous réfugiez dans le sous-sol de
la maison de votre mère en fait
illégalement ah oui parce que j'ai pas
le droit de d'y être alors vous dormez
sur un matelas pneumatique vous faites
une table de nuit avec un parpaing
heureusement un voisin vous autorise à
remplir un jerrican du jardin quoi oui
parce qu'il faut de l'eau
il faut de l'eau quand même pour au
moins se rafraîchir le visage pour boire
et oui c'est la course à l'eau alors au
Bistro vous donner des conseils
financières en échange d'un café c'est
vraiment la zone les gens savent qui je
suis devient et puis il y en a qui il y
en a qui va me voir un jour qui me dit
voilà j'ai mon portefeuille titre
qu'est-ce que tu peux me conseiller dans
les arbitrages et je commence à lui dire
des choses mais il a pas envie
d'entendre ce que je vais lui dire et là
ce qui me renvoie moi je deviens comme
Cassandre j'ai le pouvoir de dire mais
j'ai pu le pouvoir de convaincre et là
je sens qu'il me
il voit en moi le SDF alors en buvant
votre café vous lisez la bourse dans le
journal évidemment ça vous a toujours
beaucoup intéressé vous lisez des
petites annonces mais c'est difficile
parce que même pour un boulot à la
plonge vous n'avez pas la qualification
sur le mec vous dit moi j'ai des gens
qui font la planche chez moi depuis 15
ans ils savent le faire et toi va
falloir que je te forme alors que sur le
marché du travail qui vont se pointer
qui ont 10 ans d'expérience voilà alors
vous tentez tout pour retrouver du
travail mais mais c'est ça ne marche pas
quoi vous êtes complètement désespéré et
un jour vous vous rendez sur la tombe de
votre première femme huguette et voilà
vous lui dites pourquoi pourquoi m'as-Tu
abandonné quoi ma vie c'est devenu une
tartine de merde quoi et là je frôle la
folie sur la tombe du gate parce que
effectivement je lui parle je
l'invictive il y a des moments je dis
regarde tu nous as laissé tomber c'est
vraiment la merde quoi c'est clair là
vous pensez au suicide
ouais ça me traverse l'esprit et en fait
vous êtes convoqué au tribunal pour une
affaire de fraude au RMI donc vous vous
dites là ça y est je vais arriver dans
la salle du tribunal vous avez préparé
des un cocktail de médicaments je vais
les prendre en salle du tribunal en plus
Mathilde sera là comme ça elle verra le
mal qu'elle m'a fait j'ai envie de
partir sur un geste
théâtrale un coup d'éclat et c'est
décidé quoi donc je répète bien j'ai la
petite bouteille d'eau j'ai la poignée
dans la poche tout est tout est prêt et
j'attends que
le procès est reporté
c'est c'est incroyable il manque un juge
en fait le bon Dieu voulait pas de moi
ce jour-là quoi là vous sortez du
tribunal vous jetez les médicaments dans
le caniveau
et à Auxerre les rues sont pleines de
gens qui fêtent un match de la Coupe du
Monde il y a du monde vous remarquez un
journaliste et vous luttez un bout de
papier sur lequel vous avez griffonné si
le témoignage d'un ancien banquier
devenu SDF vous intéresse je suis
partant il est un peu surpris et il me
dit la seule chose que je puisse vous
promettre c'est de transmettre et voilà
quelques jours plus tard vous êtes
invités à France Bleu Auxerre pour
commencer et puis ensuite voilà on vous
entend vous retrouvez du boulot et
aujourd'hui vous êtes directeur du Magic
bowling à Nancy
j'ai beaucoup de chance j'ai beaucoup de
chance et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu